in 2019 fans of pro wrestling and bio
pigs were delighted to find out that a
hulk hogan movie is in the works
and that none other than chris hemsworth
is attached to play the lead
what's more the netflix movie will
reportedly skip all that pesky growing
up stuff
as well as mr terry bollyers and savory
late life antics
instead the film will keep a laser focus
on the times that caused the world to
know the man in the first place
the 1980s and the birth of hulkamania in
all likelihood this means yellow and red
ring gear
gloriously cheesy ring entrances amazing
supporting characters from the era's
colorful wrestling roster
and plenty of potential for awesome
stunt casting for each and every role
casting the actor who made his name
playing an actual norse god in the
marvel cinematic universe as
professional wrestling's most prominent
blonde muscle man
seems like a match made in asgard
however you can never truly know how a
man like hulk hogan is going to react to
this kind of news
people can be particular about such
things and larger than life celebrities
like hogan
likely have a few opinions about their
ideal casting
fortunately the hulk man himself finally
weighed in about marvel's store donning
his iconic handlebar mustache
here's what hulk hogan thinks about
chris hemsworth landing the role
hemsworth is doubtlessly one of
hollywood's hunkiest actors
still one look at him and say extraction
reveals that while he's a very fit man
his muscles are nowhere near the
requisite man mountain sides
to play the hulkster or rather they were
nowhere near that big
hemsworth's recent instagram post
revealed just how jacked the actor
currently is
hogan soon tweeted a reaction to the
australian's bulging musculature and he
has nothing but good things to say
in a post comparing pictures of his own
physique from his active wrestling days
and hemsworth's current chiseled body
hogan makes it clear that the actor has
his full permission to step into his
wrestling boots
hogan wrote he's already there he's
ready brother he also
jokingly wonders whether hemsworth is
good looking enough to play me
but the multiple levels that follow make
it clear that hogan harbours no
misconceptions
about the two actors relative hunkiness
on the other hand hemsworth's thor love
and thunder co-star chris pratt
is less delighted about his colleague's
impressive muscle mass
to the point that the star-lord actor
jokingly asked his name sake to tone it
down
after seeing the instagram pics pratt
wrote as a reply to hemsworth's post
hey bird just heard from my trainer and
he needs you to stop working out because
since we're going to be in the same
movie and everything
he doesn't want me to stand next to you
if you look like that so i'm gonna need
you to put on 25 pounds real quick cool
thanks since thor love and thunder plans
to start production in early 2021
it seems that pratt's star lord will
just have to deal with the hulk hogan
size thor
good luck with that petey it takes a
very special commitment to get big
enough to believably play a man who
famously refers to his arms as
24-inch pythons luckily it looks like
chris hemsworth has a pretty good idea
what he has to do
in order to get ripped enough to play
hulk hogan thanks to his experience
playing thor hemsworth obviously knows
how to get big and buff
he readily admits that this time even
the mcu's resident god of thunder
workout routine
won't do the trick the actor has stated
i will have to put on more sides than
they ever have before
even more than i put on for thor there
you have it hulk hogan is more jacked
than the actual god of thunder
yikes apart from simply getting huge his
preparation for the role also involves
getting his head around the wrestling
game i will also have to do a deep dive
into the rabbit hole of the wrestling
world which i'm really looking forward
to doing
hemsworth's trainer luke gucci is
familiar with the way the actor likes to
shape his body to fit the role
the trainer told gq he'll read the
description and come up with how he
wants to look for the role
it's almost more the look than
performance if he looks the part we've
done our job
it's not like he's competing as an
athlete judging by the reaction of the
pro wrestling legend himself
it certainly looks like hemsworth
project hulk hogan is proceeding as
planned
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]